this year's nominees for Best Supporting
Actor are distinguished as a group by
the broad and diverse range of the
characters that they played each as
memorable as any of the classic
performances were just form I am
thrilled to tell you their names
here are the nominees for performance by
an actor in a supporting role now Herr
Schuler
Ally bloom like this bridges halihan
water because Patrick Manchester lengthy
that's the time line Michael Shannon
McDonald animal
and the Oscar goes to
Mahalo Ali
this is the first Oscar and nomination
form of Ursula Holly
[Applause]
[Music]
my grandma would want me to button up
[Laughter]
Wow
I want to thank my my teachers my
professors smart I have so many
wonderful teachers and one thing that
they consistently told me is Otis to
Chandler Ron van Lew Ken Washington that
it wasn't about you
not about you it's about these
characters you're a servant you're in
service to these stories and these
characters and I'm so blessed I've had
an opportunity was about one is about
shyrone it's about Paul of cast and crew
is just such a wonderful experience
Thank You berry Jenkins Thank You 12
mccrane
a daily romansky who uh forced barry to
cast me no but it's just such a
wonderful experience and i have so many
people to thank who who got me here
my manager Carolyn Grover's will have
been with for 10 years this thank you so
much and the rest of the cast who did
wonderful work any one of them could be
up here right now holding this trophy
such a gift getting to work with you and
be inspired by you and the performances
that you all that you are offered up so
thank you the Academy really appreciate
this and lastly I just want to thank my
wife who was in her third trimester
during awards season we just had a
daughter four days ago
I just I just want to thank her for
being just such a soldier through this
process and and help them really carry
me through it all so thank you really
appreciated peace and blessings